how's it goin world my name is Matt this
is code tech and tutorials and today I'm
going to talk a little bit about I guess
two different things just mainly though
being a programmer being a coder and
what are the signs that you should be
one because let me just macam I didn't I
didn't realize it till I guess pretty
late in my my younger years my teenage
years I didn't feel like I wanted to be
a programmer but I did have an interest
in games specifically strategy games and
I also noticed that I began to notice
throughout my 20s I'm 35 now and I and
just to clarify I started pursuing being
a programmer or a code or software
developer I kind of been tying them all
together really I started pursuing that
when I was I think I was just turning 31
so I think I kind of should have done it
earlier maybe but that's neither here
nor there and I don't think it really
matters anymore actually so if you have
the mindset and that's what I'm going to
talk about the mindset if you have the
mindset where you take things very
literally or you can at least and you
tend to be good at like strategy and
putting plans together I think those are
two big signs for me it was also game
development I always I like telling
stories I always wanted to kind of make
my own world and story and that's one of
the reasons I play lots of Dungeons &
Dragons so there's all kind of went
together and I feel like I'm saying this
in a really scattered way but I hope it
makes sense and help somebody so I saw a
meme today it's been really hot I live
in Ohio and really hot for like the last
two weeks and someone posted a meme of
like someone pointing a gun at the Sun
like they're gonna kill the Sun and when
as soon as I said I saw like a bunch of
people laughing at it and yeah I get the
joke it's been hard but
if you take that literally they want to
kill the Sun okay okay what happens if
you kill the Sun well if you think
literally at all it's immediate death
for everybody on earth it's like you
you're not you're not solving the heat
problem just go get some AC so I thought
it was like the dumbest meme but
everybody is laughing at him and I
imagine none of them are programmers
because uh they think it's just like oh
it's a hot day but uh the first thing I
thought was the immediate implementation
implications of the Sun being dead and
that is well so are you
everyone is so that's just a random
example taking things literally but if
that happens to you if you see things
and they don't add up to you because you
take them literally and it's like that's
not funny that says that has results
that just aren't funny yeah well then
maybe that's a sign you should be a
programmer so a lot of people have a lot
of trouble getting past the I'll call it
the syntax step syntax is a little
intimidating say you start programming
in C++ and you want to do something but
you can't do what you want because you
don't know how to do all the logic and
make it do the stuff you want that's
only a temporary boundary some people
don't really have the logical mind to
piece things together and to think about
how things interact and intertwine and
others do so if you have a strategic
mindset the very little role mindset you
might make a really good program or her
coder and if you don't if you would look
at that meme of the guy shooting at the
Sun and just think it's hilarious and
don't even ponder that that's not what
you want to do at all because it would
kill everyone you might not want to be a
coder because uh well that's what coding
is like everything is very literal when
you're when you're doing something in
code you know exactly what you want it
to do unless you're using a random
library for like I don't know maybe
chance to hit or something
that's like the only time but even then
it's usually that's like it within a
specific range and it's like even your
randomization isn't all that random and
there's a lot more to that of course but
you usually want like a 1 to 100 and no
more something like that so you know
exactly what the possibilities are and
it's just always like that in code so if
you think in exacts I think it's worth
it to start pursuing programming learn a
few languages start getting over the
humps of learning the syntax so that you
could actually put your mind to use and
I will reiterate this by by going back
to the old days when programming first
started when computers were started none
of those people were programmers they
were just people solving problems and
doing doing math calculations on data
basically so if you like that kind of
stuff you should probably be a
programmer cuz why not it's it's a
pretty fun job you can do literally
whatever you want also it's like the
closest thing to magical powers that you
can get you can do pretty much anything
in the world with it like you want to
make a game you can do it you want to
make a face scanning app you can do it
you want to create something that's
never been done before you can probably
do it you want to make a program to do
your homework for you you could probably
do it
that's all that's gonna do for this
video I hope you enjoyed don't forget to
like if you enjoyed this video and I'll
see you the next one